io ti giuro in questo gioco non sono ma
perché rischia fino a euro
mousse in dir
[Musica]
ho fatto gli iscritti fai sta cavolo di
intro è un gioco pieno di movimento
attenzione
l'oscuro serpenti punto mi danno cielo
sponsor perché già trovarmi esatto il
basilisco va affrontato il basilisco ed
è assurdo lo sparo serpenti
ora che mi seguono al senato e va bene
con i miei sono bellissime blu tv stato
bellissimi sono che disconnesso per la
persona corona e milan vale che sono aia
e mia la collana temi una moderna
no è accaduto di tutto bye bye no salati
non attivo made it inferis non
spoilerare ma vanta due sono giallo io
mi dimentico che sono giallo maledizione
caso giu cos'è questo aiuto cosa che
spara la madonna alta seppur piuttosto
l'ho presa io ma sei scemo è
difficilissimo amico mio mi sarò
mazzarosa aiuto oddio solito grosso
ammanco e meno arrosto perché perché
dice sempre tu nostra marina che
fastidio il rosso sta aspettando che noi
buttiamo via l'ombra bene adesso abbiamo
dato via l'ombrello vice
io non so se sia una sfida una
sfidandosi figli per il culo vieni
fischiato
no io non mi muovo la carneficina è
bellissima aiuti in un affitto vieni qua
ma come millesimi da totti scattati
pulizia ma fini compito di cosa stai
facendo si fanno le family friendly
pietro dati preoccupanti mica te non ti
fa fuori ma la mira e stoffa cose sono
accadute cose ho visto avete un'amica
amica è morto luigi amico ti voglio bene
ma la logica è che io non resta che sia
successo no qualcuno spieghi che cosa è
successo non ho capito niente
no qui c'è un problema no perché così
quello che rimane suo vice per fare
tranne quando c'è l'arma giu di gesù e
il ter monya lo questo decreto che io
sia morto meno io sono morto
sto facendo finta di essere morto
prossimo con questa roba criticata
quella ciao
[Musica]
no no no dai hey hey hey pratica questa
biondina
sì ma come si sa se i meravigliosi e
tinto noce saputo che facciamo a pistoia
può chiamare io sono forte non sta
facendo niente eh sì confuso da per
piedi da solo sei morto schiacciato
cos'è quella notte ma quella no
prendermi no no mi sto progettando mag è
che lo sponsor quindi non è lancia
grazie sei feriti granata in aiuto ma mi
sono attaccata da solo quanti laser
c'erano messo il partito sotto il laser
è normale un falso mito come sai il vero
non posso scegliere la discriminazione
ma devo fare barbie per passarci sotto
oppure vincere nonostante lo svantaggio
incredibile se riuscito a perderla la
squadra ha preso io
spetta agli orti si cosa che voleva e
sparanza fortuna che tu non conosci le
sponde ti sei fatto più marito da solo
gay c'è qualche certezza c'è il terzo e
morde morto ho vinto io non ho fatto una
sega fatti una sega per tutto il livello
ho vinto io
centro al mattino l'ho presa ma sono
incastrato io sono cascato come non
posso muovermi casa cioè lo ammazzano
malizia ma lei porta malissimo dove sono
mi sa che sei morto siamo rimasti io
contro di lui il problema che sono
incastrato non conferiscono batterlo
risponde no sì sì ai miei come ho vinto
io come ricovero solo lo so non l'ho
capito come non ho capito neanche io
come ho fatto io giuro amico questi
giorni
giulia ma gesù sbagli fa io ce la fai a
fare uno sparo che sia uno il gioco
dell'anno
non ho veramente paro limbo limbo cosa
che lascia fiamme non a ciò che
realmente smartphone è pesantissimo
viene inquadrato in terra tu eri morto
da preso io spara dimenticami che
vendica di nome stesso si sta andando a
fuoco che andrà vivo come sempre a
rischio rosso e rosso
quando poi prendi lo ero
mi sa che sono nella mailing da vittore
cosa sta facendo uno per terra sono
morto spara ripeti cummings fa bastava
da sdraiato sfoga di bei ragazzi questo
è un episodio su steam fight ogni volta
ci teniamo che la metà basta ma va bene
così spero che vi sia piaciuto calabrese
riduce al momento mi piace anche la
ricerca come iscrizione commentate non
dite che me tanto si sa che ho vinto io
però ad anna giulia
ci vediamo dai
[Musica]